welcome back to Facebook guest has been
a household name for decades after
landing his first break as Luke
Skywalker in Star Wars he was catapulted
into worldwide Fame where he's resided
ever since there's more to Mark Hamill
than his on-screen triumphs he's been a
Force for good for the people of Ukraine
president zielinski personally appointed
him Ambassador for the army of drones to
help fight who tip so before I ask him
about switching from taking on Darth
Vader for helping defeat the biggest
villain on planet Earth and is rumored
love triangle with Carrie Fisher and
Harrison Ford surely not let's be
reminded of his iconic Star Wars role as
Luke Skywalker
a little short for a Storm Trooper huh
oh the uniform
I'm Luke Skywalker I'm here to rescue
you
I am the father
now
well I guess you don't know everything
about women yet
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
take your fathers please set my side
I'll never turn to the dark side
well Mark Hamill joins me now mark thank
you so much for joining the program
thanks for having me I want to start
with a dramatic confession
um because I know that you were
complaining in a recent interview that
you always have to talk about Star Wars
in interviews I can probably make that
easier for you because I I have never
watched any of the Star Wars movies
well that's
Viva La difference you know I'm glad I'm
glad people don't uh all like the same
things it'd be very boring I'm going to
say that nobody's standing there my
eldest son discovered that you were on
tonight I don't think I've ever known
him more excited he's nearly 30. he has
one of those things that you wave around
I know in the movies the the lightsaber
Lifesavers
um and he is so incredibly excited about
this so I might at the end just ask you
to send him the force or or whatever it
is but you'll be pleased to know I'm
gonna Focus right now on uh something
much dearer to my heart which is Ukraine
I went to Ukraine uh back in July and I
went to see President zielinski
interviewed him and his wife the first
lady and I was struck by a lot of things
about them I think they're a remarkable
couple and he's a remarkable leader in
this incredibly difficult time
um but I also was struck by something
you said about about this when you spoke
to him on zoom and you're reflecting on
it afterwards that he was a guy who was
an actor like you you know he was a guy
just basically running a TV production
company taking part as a comedic actor
and then he he ends up playing somebody
who randomly runs for president uh in a
comedy
and then he ultimately runs for
president
he becomes president and within a year
he's plunged into the first major war in
Europe since the second world war it's
an extraordinary story isn't it as
someone who's obviously an actor like
him what do you make of it
it really it it really is and uh uh I I
first became aware of him during the
first impeachment trial and did my
research and like you say he started out
as an actor life imitates art he wound
up doing a series called servant of the
people which I also watched he's an
inspirational leader and the way the
Ukrainian people have come together in
in these in these terrible times I mean
like you say we've never seen a
sovereign nation invaded uh by a hostile
foreign Nation since World War II no
you've got involved in a really
brilliant campaign I think which is
about the use of drones to monitor the
two and a half thousand kilometers front
line in Ukraine
um it's called United 24 and the way it
works in as I'm mistaken is that people
like yourself have been raising money
and awareness for this and then the
drones are sent to Ukraine for them to
use and in fact you'd have been directly
responsible for over 500 drones now
being sent over to Ukraine and they are
incredibly useful because they are
basically the eyes and ears for the
Ukrainian people in detecting missiles
and so on exactly
exactly in in a simple statement Ukraine
needs drones drones Define War outcomes
and they're able to monitor the Border
uh and protect both civilians and their
soldiers so what surprised me was not
only were they interested in in
fundraising but if you have a drone I
was unaware that this is a popular Hobby
and people that are hobbyists that are
focused on drones they have uh multiple
drones they say oh well that's two years
ago that's the old model I've got the
updated version and Ukraine can use even
the most simplistic drones they don't
fly very far but like you say they're
the eyes in the sky and it's really
crucial now that Russia is struggling on
the Battle Front they've been attacking
behind the battlefield
bombing civilian infrastructure schools
playgrounds it's really terrible yeah
and not to mention the fact that for the
last four weeks uh the large portions of
Ukraine have no water right there's
power outages so anything that can be
done to to help is greatly greatly
appreciated when you spoke to president
zielinski in this Zoom conversation I
know that Star Wars did come up and of
course the parallel I think that you
both realize which is pretty pretty
Stark actually is that the themes of the
Star Wars movies were always about good
taking on evil and good ultimately
triumphing here you have a really I
think a pretty clear-cut example of good
people of Ukraine being illegally
invaded by bad people Vladimir Putin and
his Russian military how do you think
this ends I mean are we going to be in a
position where like in a movie good well
ultimately Triumph or is it more is it
going to be more difficult than that
well it's impossible to say I mean
everyone expected Ukraine to just roll
over and give up instead they've mounted
this
ferocious resistance uh and they're
making great strides I I pray that uh
Putin finds some face-saving event to
say okay I've accomplished what I wanted
and we're pulling out because uh he's
been humiliated uh uh and and that's not
good for someone
as aggressive as he is right so um I I
don't know it's just terrible over 115
countries now have donated not just to
Army of drones but you know uh uh
zielinski appointed various ambassadors
I know leave Schreiber is in charge of
one aspect Barbra Streisand another
aspect uh Imagine Dragons the musical
group and they there are all
have their separate responsibilities
mind being the army of drones well I
think I think it's I'm just I think it's
brilliant honestly I think when I was
there the resilience of that of the
people Ukraine was incredibly palpable
they don't want to give Putin an inch
and they are desperate for support and
help from the rest of us in the west and
I think they'll be hugely appreciative
as I know zelenski was about what you've
been doing and using your profile for
doing that so
um you know really well done and keep up
that great work and we'll certainly
direct people from this show to to work
out how they can get involved too I want
to just pivot slightly to to can I can I
mention the yes if I could can I mention
the website really quick it's you two
for
u24.gov which is
gov.ua forward slash dronation right
u24.gov dot u a forward slash Dro
n-a-t-i-o-n well I will be able to I
will set and I will tweet that to my 8
million Twitter followers which I passed
this morning Mark uh now I've actually
had a little Spurt of followers in the
last couple of weeks you've had the
opposite and you're blaming Elon Musk
yeah
no I'm not I I just stated the fact that
I lost over 6 000 in the first three
days it was weird then I gained them
back and then some and now I've fallen
back another ten thousand I'm not
blaming anybody I just don't understand
what's going on how many do you have
spots how many photos you have
if I have five point
two and I just got over 5.3 and then I
lost and went back to 5.2 but you know
it's every Everything's Relative you
know when I start thinking wow I've got
five million followers and you find out
like Taylor Swift has 180 million or
something so I mean I've got to say I'm
because I'm quietly pleased I've got
three million more than Luke Skywalker
well there you go
congratulations uh but on a serious
point maybe if you watch the movie if
you watch the movies you'll go up even
higher you know what I am gonna I am
going to my son has been on and on at me
about I can't tell you what a massive
fan he is
um what do you think about Elon Musk
wanting to charge People Like Us uh to
have to keep our Blue Tick are you gonna
pay him his eight dollars a month
no you know it reminds me they I got
contacted by the who's who people and
they wanted me to be in Who's Who and
then when I found out there was a 250
fee I said what are they crazy if I'm
really somebody they'll put me in
without the fee so I didn't pay it I
don't know whether I'm in it or not but
I think that's ridiculous I don't
understand I mean uh
when I went on Twitter they just gave me
that check and I guess it's just to
authenticate that it's really you but uh
I've been on Twitter for so long now I
don't think I'll miss it
I think people know what it finds your
way um what is the best or worst thing
about being Luke Skywalker one of the
all-time iconic movie roles best of
worst
well um
one of the best things is that
people feel like they know you so
wherever I go
uh people talk about how those films
affected their lives whether it got them
through a parent's illness or uh you
know they met their future spouse
at a screening I mean people relate it
in such personal ways it it means a lot
I don't know what the worst thing is I
guess it's because uh you know when I do
something and it's over I just let it go
and
I have these kids that come up to me and
not just kids you know adults as well
that know so much more about it than I
do because I don't watch them over and
over I watch them when they came out and
I don't watch them again so they know
details that I I don't know what they're
talking about and he says is there any
prosperity of Luke raising his
lightsaber again or is it all over
oh it's over
really is over Mark if you could just do
me one favor and make me farther of the
Year could you just stare down the
barrel of the camera and say Spencer
Morgan May the force be with you
Spencer Morgan the force will be with
you always
[Laughter]
that's absolutely fantastic uh Mark
Hamill what a pleasure to have you on
the program thank you so much
thanks for having me Pierce and keep up
the great work in Ukraine it's it's a
hugely appreciated by by them all there
I know and very important work thank you
very much all the left